it's effectively signed sealed delivered
the trade agreement between Canada and
Europe known as theta is a big deal for
both sides new trade deals are basically
one of the major major sources of our
wealth and it's not possible to imagine
that we could make any trade deal with
any other country or region if we can't
do this is Canadian seven years in the
making businesses will soon see Paris
removed on most goods and services and
have easier access to each other's
market diplomas will be mutually
recognized once in full swing trade
between the two is set to increase by
twenty percent the bills against theta
are still concerned the deals with
corporations before people they worry
governments will have less power to
protect health safety labor or the
environment this deal will not undermine
our health review will not decrease
European standards this deal will not be
capable also to decrease the sovereignty
of the thing also one of the 43 product
specific to a region in the eve you from
Roquefort cheese to Medina balsamic
vinegar will be protected from imitation
with Parliament's approval most of the
agreement could apply from as early as
spring one last hurdle remains only
after all national parliaments have
ratified the deals can feed out this
fully in place
you